now we head to the Washington swamp
where president uh Biden once again is
having a very hard time mired and
Scandal and plagued by his own cognitive
decline Joe Biden decided to take a big
trip away from the Oval Office today he
actually managed to travel a whole 10
miles crossing the mighty Potomac
Potomac River into Northern Virginia wow
what a long trip unfortunately the
purpose for this outing was not exactly
clear and his bizarre disjointed speech
was almost impossible for anybody to
comprehend we've got the videotape you
decide
when I was seeking the nomination I said
take a seat everybody and there wasn't a
single chair in the place
I said that Biden really is stupid he
doesn't know it where's Doug
congressman
he's around here somewhere I've been
saying this during the last campaign in
the off your campaign Doug knows look
here's the deal you know they view the
world from Park Avenue
I view it where the wealthy in fact you
get and if everything works well for
them all that's going to trickle down
and help the rest of us well I come from
a background where that never worked
talk about being deprived of your pride
look at your child
your child if you don't think we have a
climate crisis come travel with me
around the country
no I'm not joking go back
go back
and here we are no president added more
to the debt in four years than my
president
I I bespoke 25 percent of our country's
entire debt
not very good anyway I think we all know
uh who is Doug memory loss difficulty
communicating finding words difficulty
with handling complex complex tasks
those are symptoms of dementia ask
yourself is this the person that's
really capable of conducting debt
ceiling negotiations is he able to act
in good faith does he really fully
comprehend and understand what is
exactly going on because for two years
your president Joey Biden was able to
hide behind the democratic-controlled
house senate and the media mob protected
him but now for the first time in his
presidency Joe your president will face
legitimate oversight if and only if
House Republicans stick together hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else